So in this last section, we're going to discuss the combined approaches, of
which there are three. When we combine psycho therapy and drugs and integrative
therapy and mindfulness training and drugs. So let's talk about the first one
first. Psychotherapy and drugs, so this is in fact a very effective and popular
combination when we're treating anxiety and mood disorders. So the idea here is
that the drugs will focus on and alleviate the anxiety of mood disorder,
whereas as the psychotherapy helps the person manage their irrational thoughts.
So another common combination treatment in therapy is when we combine cognitive
behavioral therapy with drug therapy to treat depression. In fact, sometimes we
also have in this mix a token economy behavior modification therapy. In fact,
that combination of drug and token economy behavior modification is also seen
in treating children with ADHD. So the idea is that this stimulant medication
will help control some of the symptoms. And then every time the child acts in a
non-hyperactive way, they get reinforced with a token.